either the Commerce Clause gives
Congress a plenary power to regulate
anything it pleases or a dozen let's
have that argument hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and today we're talking
with David Bernstein the author most
recently of rehabilitating Lochner
defending individual rights against
progressive reform he's also a law
professor at George Mason University
David thanks for joining us thanks for
having me the Lochner decision describe
it briefly and what is the controversy
that surrounds this so New York State
had a law that said that bakers were not
allowed to work even voluntarily more
than 60 hours per week and the case
eventually made the Supreme Court a
Baker named Joseph Lochner challenged
the law and the Supreme Court ultimately
a very controversial closed five-to-four
decision held that the law violated the
right to liberty of contracts which the
courts that was implicit in the 14th
Amendment's Due Process Clause so the I
mean the court in Lochner basically the
court says no actually you can work as
much as you want or as little as you
want or at least that you can come into
60 hours right you can't single out
bakers there's why why bakers there's no
good reason to single out bakers bakers
are adults they have no particular
disabilities are not living in some
isolated company talent they can't
escape from they're just as capable as
everybody else if you're limiting just
bakers we think maybe there's some kind
of reason behind it that is not really a
health reason so a or it's like they're
flying obviously not in 1895 but they're
flying airplanes you know so they might
be tired and there's a public health
risk or something now Lochner remains
very controversial in 2005 when Barack
Obama was a senator and California
Supreme Court justice Janice Roger
Rogers Brown was being considered for
the US Court of Appeals in the District
of Columbia Circuit he said about her
one of the things that is most troubling
is justice Browns approval of the
Lochner era of the Supreme Court keep in
mind that same judicial philosophy was
underpinning was the underpinning of
Dred Scott the decision that said that
men have black people have no rights of
whites need respect
why is Lochner still in flaming passions
it seems like a pretty cut and drug
thing and why is it being compared with
Dred Scott so justice all the way though
Holmes who was the great progressive
hero of the early 20th century in the
Supreme Court were famous lone dissent
in Lochner where he talked about the
right of the majority to enact that our
will into law said there's no such thing
as Liberty of contract Justice Holmes is
dissent became a famous dissent that
both liberals and conservatives used for
their own purposes so liberals use it to
say that the Supreme Court should never
get involved in economic matters at all
I believe that's a democracy otherwise
corporate plutocracies will be able to
work that our will on poor workers
conservatives use it to say that the due
process clause which has also been used
to protect all sorts of rights including
very controversial abortion should not
play any role in constitutional
jurisprudence basically it protects only
procedure no substitute so both sides
just by happenstance really decide to
use lock they're ultimately as their
symbolic case for everything that's
wrong with the other sighs jurisprudence
so you're rehabilitated Lochner in your
book and what how hard a job is that I
mean is is there a swelling movement to
say you know what no Lochner is right
there are rights you know to contract
individual rights that cannot be
legislated away nor should be legislated
away is that becoming more popular and
if so how is it going to change the
legal landscape in the future well when
you see really prominent not just law
professors but even prominent
politicians like Barack Obama comparing
this relatively mild and not not
especially important in historical
context a Supreme Court opinion to Dred
Scott the infamous pro-slavery case
that's obviously pretty hard to overcome
that strong historical story that's been
accepted about Lochner but I think what
I think that conservatives and liberals
each have some reason to reassess
lopping or liberals to the extent that
they support unenumerated rights like
abortion they have you know either
you've made up a whole cloth or there's
at least a constitutional tradition
saying that the state's so-called police
power regulatory power does have
some limits on the other hand
conservatives are in this awkward
position where they want to say for
example Obamacare goes beyond Congress's
commerce power and they want to hark
back to some of the precedents from the
same time as Lochner they want so on the
one hand they're arguing yes the
Commerce Clause should be more limited
as we held the 1920s a 1910 on the other
hand in cases like lockers Supreme Court
a bunch of bozos who are just making
stuff up
well those bozos were making stuff up
maybe that means their Commerce Clause
cases weren't stupid either so I think
each side has some incentive to reassess
what was going on I think there is some
reassessment on both sides going on in
it you brought up the health care reform
case that is clearly going to be going
to the individual mandate the limits of
the Congress's Commerce Clause powers do
you have a sense of how Lochner will
play out or where will that convince
more justices say the individual mandate
is beyond the pale or that it's totally
within the Legislature's right well the
ghosts of Locke there clearly has some
of an anti libertarian bias in the sense
that if you think that laughter was
wrongly decided because either the court
should interpret constitutional rights
narrowly in general or because you think
as the Liberals argue that the court to
stay out of economic matters that
obviously creates a disincentive for
judges to buck that but I think by
taking Lochner seriously as doctrine
maybe it was correctly decided maybe it
wasn't but it wasn't this outrageous
crazy evil opinion we could then say
okay so if Flocker wasn't that
outrageous then let's take the Commerce
Clause case as it comes that's not it's
not how that you do have Locke no it's a
different provision of the Constitution
either the Commerce Clause gives
Congress a plenary power to regulate
anything it pleases or a dozen let's
have that argument I think it doesn't
but we can at least argue that without
having to bring in this kind of
irrelevant case from 100 or five years
ago David Bernstein of George Mason
University Law School as well as the
author most recently of rehabilitating
Lochner which is available from the
University of Chicago Press thanks for
talking to recentiy V thanks so much for
having me